oh geez hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to torpor now
this game is supposed to be a narrative
experience or maybe not even narrative
it's about the story of a soldier who
I'm assuming oh hi what in the world
whoa it's about a soldier who was just
shot and either his life is flashing
before his eyes or I don't know
something I have no idea I'm going into
this pretty blind why is there a baby
crib there
this is unsettling it's just weird it's
jarring because I just got in the game
and as soon as I loaded it up bang we're
here what is this I mean obviously it's
someone's home
they had a loving family I'm assuming
because of this game about a soldier
getting shot it's gonna be sad I been
and it seems to be like World War 2 era
I'm not entirely mistaken but no hello
hi also I never even realized how weird
it was that the soldier had a teddy bear
with him at the time of his do these
things trigger met oh oh oh so the
things with the weird glows around him
trigger memories where am I hello hello
oh this is creepy I don't even know if
this game was supposed to be creepy well
geez I can't get on they're not allowed
okay so is it happening it's just so
oddly bizarre I mean when I went into
this I was assuming it was gonna be a
sad experience but I can't go this way
either well which way am I supposed to
go
am I supposed to do oh oh that was
glowing I didn't even realize that is so
cool oh I'm in the sky oh I'm a
paratrooper I'm up shits about to go
down
holy [ __ ] so this is like reliving
moments of his life that lead up to his
death then in that house would there was
more than one thing that I could have
clicked on so weird
Oh time to go apparently back here what
I guess that led up to the moment
immediately before his death but not not
the right moment that I'm looking for
though oh that's so cool you're
searching through his memories until you
get to the right place or at least
that's what I assumed it is I'm not on
represent sure but it could be Turk lon
no but there was a glow on the jacket in
here yeah that's so weird
oh oh oh
whoa-ohh is the only thing any or that
teddy bear could there be something else
hidden in the pews probably not oh
that's so weird it's just like what's
fascinating about this game is just the
jarring transitions of it the immediate
snap back and forth through reality so
there must be something else that I
haven't touched there must be a few
things man straight to the funeral oh
man someone was trying to write a lot of
letters
wait the suitcase is gone now could
there be other things here or maybe I'm
just gonna be stuck in limbo in this
area forever and ever I refuse to
believe that there's got to be something
here ah here we go oh this is bad
connotations if it's a bottle of pills
but here we go
oh oh
therapy oh oh that's that's fun
Oh yep that's not fun that was a thing
I'm gonna get back to I didn't realize
the other thing before I click on okay
here we go
where are we going oh man well I know
what the guns do I don't want to touch
the guns oh man
it's literally nothing but guns that's
not good I know what every single one of
those go to Oh No but there's a there's
bills their apologies leads back to this
room except with less gun about the box
of tissues no just a bunch of gun it's
all gun jeez I'm gonna try the pills Oh
are these not these aren't working
anymore ha the pills don't work anymore
gun it is then yep oh I thought it was
gonna come back here
so bizarre so bizarre it's so bizarre
so weird so is there anything else in
here that I've missed the pills are gone
the jackets still there let's check it's
still there unless I didn't find what I
was looking for in there the only reason
these would still be here is to find
something else right can't go around the
casket there can click on that so
there's got to be something else besides
the bear oh I don't see anything else so
I'm assuming man's got to be something
else Oh
the pills are back that's what wait
those are gone but now the pills are
back but now the suitcase is in that
room why is that in there why are the
pills back is this gonna lead to
something new no it's the same thing
it's the same dang thing it's just a
loop I got to find out more about this
maybe I'm doing something wrong here oh
oh oh my god ok alright I guess that's
it it says that I'm there's all the
paths and it shows like the timeline of
everything going through and where
everything leads I don't know why I
expected there to be an ending to this
considering that it started at the end
of this soldiers life I guess that's the
end man that's that's weird and actually
quite profound because it's like one of
those situations where I don't want to
accept the end but it is what it is the
guy's dead what more is there to say
there's little bits and storytelling in
the environment itself like why was
therapy there is that the grieving widow
or did they go to therapy together
because their marriage wasn't working
why was there a baby crib there like why
was known at the funeral why did he have
the teddy bear with him while he was
going there maybe the child died and he
took that teddy bear with him
war I have no idea there's a lot of
things open to interpretation and I
don't think anyone's gonna be satisfied
with one particular answer but as far as
a narrative experience that has
absolutely no talking besides my own
that was fascinating that was really
fascinating I feel like it could be
fleshed out more though I feel like it
is just very shallow depth you know
storytelling here but there's this style
I like it a lot I like this story
storytelling style this is really cool
so thank you developers for making the
game and thank you everybody for
watching I hope to see more stuff like
this in the near future because it's so
interesting to just try to go through
the environment and seek out clues on
your own and build the story from your
own imagination so either way thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye